ce sont des monuments historiques devant
lesquels nous passons tous les jours des
vestiges de l'histoire comme le char
duguay-trouin mais savons-nous vraiment
ce qu'il représente
j'ai toujours habité des gens j'ai
jamais lu la pancarte qui était en
dessous il a servi il a servi exactement
je n'ai jamais eu l'occasion d'aller
m'approcher si vous voulez alors pour
remédier à cela la ville a mis en place
une carte interactive grâce à des
indicateurs de couleur il sera possible
de découvrir les lieux emblématiques de
la ville de la guerre de 1870 jusqu'au
conflit algérien alors là on se trouve
devant un bâtiment qui a le bâtiment qui
a abrité gestapo donc la police secrète
d'état pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale un bâtiment réquisitionné en
août 1940 un lieu de torture aujourd'hui
quasiment oublié par les dijonnais peut
très bien passer à côté sans se rendre
compte véritablement de ce qui a pu se
passer à l'intérieur de ses murs
c'est précisément pour lutter contre
l'oubli que la ville a pensé ce parcours
mémorielle qu'il s'agit de faire en
sorte que les dijonnais revivent leur
histoire et et puisse ainsi faire
revivre si ce parcours mémorielle un
travail important de collecte de données
d'une trentaine de sites sur ce tableau
la barricade érigée dans la rue jeannin
en octobre 1870 symbole de la résistance
des dijonnais à l'invasion prussienne
aujourd'hui il ne reste aucune trace de
cet événement et là encore l'application
sert à raviver la mémoire
ça m'a quand même qui est relativement
célèbre dans l'histoire de la ville mais
néanmoins il est certain que mon nombre
de dijonnais à qui vous poseraient la
question ne seront pas forcément qu'il
ya eu cet événement
dans dans la rue jeanne à ce parcours
mémorielle doit s'étoffer dans les
prochains mois grâce aux contributions
des habitants cent dix monuments doivent
encore trouver leur place sur la carte
de la ville